et xavier bertrand est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir monsieur le
ministre de l'emploi du travail et de la
santé et merci d'être avec nous en ce
1er mai c'est la première fois
d'ailleurs que vous manifestez vous
descendez dans la rue un 1er mai xavier
bertrand qu'on se rassemble pour
élaborer ensemble dans la rue beau
rassemblement populaire
bref on était à la concorde voilà de
cela quelques semaines oui il parle du
pourquoi c'était interdit le problème si
je reste je vous pose la première fois
que vous descendez dans la rue un 1er
mai non mais ça veut dire quoi pour
défiler on n'a pas défilé
mais je savais pas que c'était interdit
pour pour nous nous rassembler le 1er
mai il y avait un couvre feu qui avait
été mis en place par monsieur mélenchon
par madame aubry par monsieur hollande
je savais pas que c'était interdit ben
je vais vous dire une chose j'étais tout
à l'heure au trocadéro et ben on a bien
fait de nous retrouver très bien on a
bien failli se rassembler ce qu'on
laisse aller les choses à dire sur les
rails on les a vu les drapeaux bleu
blanc rouge de roncq 1 que nicolas
sarkozy veut opposer au drapeau rouge
bien ceux des cortèges des syndicats
c'est bien cela mais les drapeaux du
front national ont aussi flotté en ce
1er mai du travail premier prophète du
travail plus divisé que jamais l'un
comme le pays marine le pen votera blanc
et gérard longuet votre collègue du
gouvernement
la voient comme un interlocuteur de
l'ump dans une interview au journal
d'extrême droite minute dans un instant
frédéric dumoulin de l' agence
france-presse vous interrogera sur ce
point et puis ce sera le tour de perrine
tarneaud de public sénat
je note que les téléspectateurs peuvent
intervenir durant cette émission en vous
posant des questions
par le biais de l'application tivi
tchèque d'orange d'abord et xavier
bertrand martine aubry déplore ce contre
1er mai donc cette fête du trocadéro de
nicolas sarkozy elle dit c'est un moment
division supplémentaire
elle manque pas d'air elle va pas nous
donner le sont quand même surtout madame
aubry pour parler du travail quand elle
a à l'époque punit les ouvriers et les
employés en leur faisant payer à eux la
facture des 35 heures et elle va donner
des leçons elle préférait quoi elle
préférait se livrer à une énième
tentative de récupération des défilés
syndicaux parce que c'était sain qui
était prévu c'est ça qui était prévu
c'était madame aubry monsieur mélenchon
en tête
dans les cortèges syndicaux et là
monsieur gérer le côté vous avez regardé
ce que monsieur charest a aussi remis à
leur place
monsieur chérèque à l'issue d'un défilé
syndical et y aura pas de récupération
politique et donc que ça leur plaise ou
non la gauche et l'extrême gauche ont
été obligés d'être spectateur ou de
suivre et pas de récupérer vrai
changement vrai changement mais au moins
le trocadéro donc c'était un meeting
électoral
c'était également un rassemblement
contre le 1er mai traditionnel gagne en
ne retenant pas contre le 1er mai
traditionnels elle est jusqu'au bout
dans votre esprit c'est quoi ce serait
celui des syndicats non non moi j'ai
aucun problème avec les syndicats qui
font du syndicalisme comme vous avez des
syndicats qui sont dans le dialogue
social
où est le problème il n'y en a aucun
dans ce quinquennat il n'y a jamais eu
autant d'accords nationaux
interprofessionnels que pendant ce
quinquennat mais il faut bien
reconnaître que quand il ya des réformes
très importantes qui sont indispensables
comme les retraites les syndicats ne
sont pas accompagnés c'est leur choix
mais taylor droit de contester qu'on ne
reproche pas aussi aux politiques
le fait de vouloir avancer moderniser le
pays pas pour nous faire plaisir mais
parce que c'est essentiel si on n'avait
pas fait la réforme des retraites
nous ne pourrions pas dire aux français
toutes vos retraites seront payées
tout le monde les touchera et en plus
elles seront payées le 1er du mois et je
note parce que j'ai entendu cet
après-midi au début du cortège syndical
monsieur thibault une fois de plus mal
inspirés ou pas au courant dire que les
pensions avaient baissé en france je le
mets au défi je me défie ce soir de dire
quelle pension de retraite abaissé si si
peut-être qu'il parlait de la grèce ou
du portugal ou de l'espagne
parce qu'à l'époque eux n'ont pas fait
leurs efforts ils rappellent ceux qui
voient leur pension peut être reporté un
peu plus tard j'assume tout à fait le
fait que nous ayons demandé de
travailler deux ans de plus d'ici 2018
mais la contrepartie de ces deux ans de
plus c'est qu'on ne prend pas tous les
ans 20 milliards d'euros dans la poche
des français en impôts et on peut
regarder tout le monde en disant les
retraites seront payées
donc quand monsieur thibault dit que les
pensions ont baissé c'est faux c'est
faux alors je sais qu'il a
un peu la tête ailleurs en ce moment
monsieur thibault il a changé de métier
il était syndicaliste
il est devenu politicien hier avec
monsieur mélenchon aujourd'hui avec
monsieur hollande
ça vous étonne franchement il a dit
qu'il allait voter alors ce n'est pas
une surprise
non ce n'est pas une surprise mais
ferait mieux de s'occuper de sa maison
parce qu'en terme d'élections
l'élection de son successeur à la tête
de son organisation visiblement ça se
passe pas bien et il en est le premier
responsable pour sa séparation un terme
provisoire à agent électoral qu'il reste
dans le syndic et alors vous vous en
prenez depuis quelques jours à bernard
thibault dans ces lieux qui a commencé à
appeler sur un terrain politique
il sera resté dans le registre syndical
on peut la voir comme interlocuteur
maxime pas facile c'est pas le sujet
mais il s'est placé sur un terrain
politique et voulez que je dise sa
sortie de route la sortie de route de la
cgt j'aime les autres syndicats et fait
du mal à la neutralité syndicale
françois chérèque a pris quelques
distances avec cet engagement partisan
néanmoins sur les verrous en ce qui
prouve bien que la neutralité syndicale
c'est un mec qui est auquel tiennent les
organes et en moins radicale le leader
de la cfdt souligne qu'elle sera très
difficile selon lui de rétablir un
climat de confiance
si nicolas sarkozy est réélu heures il
dit à sa manière peut-être plus feutrée
finalement la même chose que bernard
thibault
je pas entendu le dire sa pioche côté
françois shine a parlé d'un climat
combien d'années qui détériorerait
attendait s'il avait envie d'appeler à
voter pour quelqu'un je connais son
caractère il le dirait il ne le fait pas
il reste donc dans la neutralité
maintenant vous vous dites est ce qu'il
sera facile ou pas de discuter dans les
années qui viennent c'est ce que dit
françois chérèque il le dit j'ai entendu
la même chose en 2007
oui parce que parce qu'avec nicolas
sarkozy et ce qui sera possible de
discuter de dialoguer les mêmes
remarques faites bien souvent par les
mêmes je sais j'étais ministre du
travail en 2007 et j'étais porte parole
de nicolas sarkozy les mêmes propos
reviennent aujourd'hui et vous savez
quoi
on a au coeur de la crise trouver des
syndicats qui y ont salué les réactions
et les décisions du président de la
république et avec lesquels sur nombre
de dossiers on a pu avancer pas sur tous
le vrai sujet c'est que dans les années
qui viennent
il nous faudra aller plus loin sur
nombre de
forme justement je vais vous interrogé
là-dessus j'ai bien écouté le discours
de nicolas sarkozy mais j'avais encore
une question sur les responsables
syndicaux que vous épinglez différemment
bien sûr on l'a entendu l'instant
néanmoins néant matatu sont entendus
lundi faire ce qu'ils font du syndicat
devient les différentes par exemple
justement quand laurence parisot a salué
l'extraordinaire boulot accompli par
nicolas sarkozy vous avez été heurtée je
ne sais pas par un manque de neutralité
de sa part où l'eau peut équilibrer les
choses quelques jours après avant alors
entendu elle a plutôt équilibrée les
choix après la franche est plutôt du
côté de hollande quelques jours après
vous avez noté ça vous a fait sourire
comme histoire là oui ça me fait sourire
elle trouve que bien ça parce que vous
savez voir des syndicats vous savez
carita risme a du bon je crois une chose
c'est qu'on attend des représentants des
syndicats de salariés comme des
organisations
c'est qu'il soit aussi force de
propositions j'attends notamment du
medef des idées sur la simplification de
la vie des entreprises un allègement des
charges administratives des entreprises
tous les déplacements que je fais sur le
terrain tous les chefs d'entreprises les
professionnels me dise voilà ce que l'on
attend moins de charges sociales moins
de charges administratives dans les
dialogues avec les institutionnels se
sont pas les mêmes sujets qu avec les
professionnels alors voilà pourquoi je
passe autant de temps sur le terrain
aussi avec l'échelle on va le voir il va
leur en on vous a suivi à saumur en or
un reportage tout à l'heure en tous les
cas donc laurence parisot il pense d'une
éponge des côtés de françois hollande
dans la défense et sa vision des fameux
corps intermédiaires notamment les
syndicats c'est ce qu'avait dit on on
peut dire un mot sur ce sujet il est
important oui le dialogue social
il est essentiel dans notre pays mais
c'est un moyen de trouver des solutions
pas une fin en soi et je vous dire on a
pris aussi des habitudes en france
depuis quelques années c'est que bien
souvent les partenaires sociaux entre
eux préfèrent avoir un accord signé par
100 % des participants
mais pour une réforme qui va seulement à
50% du chemin alors que je pense qu'il
faut le contraire il faut dans les
années qui viennent parce que la
compétition internationale est là parce
qu'il faut booster la compétitivité des
entreprises
il faut les accords compétitivité emploi
il faut changer la donne en matière de
formation des demandeurs d'emploi et sur
ces points là on pourra pas avoir de
blocage lui donne on pourra pas avoir de
réforme
à mi chemin il faudra aller au bout des
réformes et si si les partenaires
sociaux ne voulait pas s'engager
c'est leur droit il faudra pas s'étonner
dans ces cas là que le politique
président de la république l'a dit à
chaud m des missions au peuple ça a été
dès les accords de compétitivité la
formation des chômeurs notamment mais il
ya une nouvelle voie tu me semble utile
qui a été tracé tout à l'heure par
nicolas sarkozy il dit qu'il faut un
nouveau modèle social l'annoncé au
trocadéro c'est dire que il dévoile en
fait son projet qui est de s'attaquer
aux rigidités du monde du travail vous
pouvez me confirmer je vous lis mais les
accords compétitivité emploi c'est
l'exemple ne pense pas aujourd'hui
prenez la rupture conventionnelle alors
pour demain parce que parce que ça c'est
d'accord ça a été accompli non mais par
exemple il on parle maintenant
s'attaquer au code du travail s'est
amusé à le brûler en place de grève
un nouveau ni un modèle social en france
en france est un pays sérieux où on a
des dossiers des sujets qui sont sérieux
ça veut dire quoi s'attaquer ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire tout simplement
qu'il ya la loi et que la loi doit fixer
un cadre mais qu'ensuite vous devez
donner de la place à la discussion la
négociation ou salaces ou plein moussa
dans l'entreprise au plus près du
terrain je n'ai rien contre les branches
professionnelles
mais je pense que là vous avez le
maximum de pragmatisme maximum
d'efficacité c'est dans l'entreprise et
pas le patron qui va décider tout seul
c'est pas ce que souhaitent les
employeurs mais qu'ils en discutent avec
les représentants du personnel et le
personnel l'avenir pour les discussions
pour les négociations
c'est la loi qui fixe un cadre et la
négociation dans l'entreprise
voilà autant de sujets sur lesquels là
je le pense il faut que l'on puisse
avancer et encore une fois ce n'est pas
pour faire plaisir à untel ou untel
c'est une question de compétitivité des
entreprises et il n'y a que monsieur
mélenchon qui pensent encore que la
lutte des classes intéresse quelqu'un
dans ce pays monsieur mélenchon
vous dire hormis les éliminés du premier
tour oui il fallait peut-être éliminés
c'est vrai que lui qui était
révolutionnaire révolutionnaire incarne
effet fait homme qui aussitôt celui qui
nous faisait comprendre que la machine à
remonter le temps existait kitty
aussitôt à faire à rentrer toutes ses
griffes
au soir des produits ça m'étonnerait que
pour les législatives on ne l'entendent
plus mais en attendant lui l'a pas
compris que quand ce qui est bon pour
l'entreprise c'est bon pour l'emploi
alors ça les salariés l'ont compris vous
avez rappelé que les syndicats demain
aurait toute leur place
1 et leur rôle à jouer on n'a pas très
bien compris ce drôle de jeu entre
nicolas sarkozy et françois fillon un
ces derniers jours le premier ministre
est clairement pris ses distances
franchement avec nicolas sarkozy quand
il a dit qu'il me fallait cesser
qu'est ce qu'il a dit de toutes
remarques désagréables contre
franchement oui c'est l'amusement
franchement j -c la même partition il ya
toujours un jeu est-ce qu'on pourrait
pas regarder dans telle phrase ceux qui
n'iraient pas 100% dans la ligne de ce
qui a été dit par tes mots de mais je
sais rien et personne ne le regarde et
vois sourire et regardez votre sourire
mais projet permet d' aveux c'est un peu
la même je comprends que ce puisse être
tombée la politique et on cajole et les
syndicats comme françois hollande c'est
parce que le dis vous l'avez écouté ce
matin là oui je n'écoutais c'est que nos
confrères de rtl
oui et puis j'ai vu après ce qui a été
retranscrit dance kids avis c'était la
même ligne entendons nous bien
les syndicalistes qui font du
syndicalisme bien évidemment il s'agit
pas de se heurter ceux qui sont des
représentants maintenant pour ceux qui
font de la politique ce n'est plus le
même registre c'est vrai alors donc
françois chérèque s'est trompé et
l'huile a dénoté une sorte de
schizophrénie à droite 1
le ministre de la santé que je suis vous
dit le primat de schizophrénie a drop
bien
c'est vrai que vous avez épuisé tous les
crédits d'aidé des fonds et aider pour
l'emploi alors que la gauche s'apprête
évidemment vous l'avez entendu à prendre
le pouvoir et pourrait arriver la gauche
après tu françois hollande a dit qu'il
se voyait vainqueur c'est lui et donc
qu'est ce que c'est ils seront s'il ya
une alternance est ce qu'il y aura
encore des fonds est ce que les heures
emplois aidés xavier bertrand c'est la
question que je vous pose quand vous me
dites ça de la gauche demande si chez
monsieur hollande c'est un roc en nous
méprisant le bon adjectif qui s'y croit
déjà il sait pas comment se passent ces
actions il se définit aujourd'hui
dépeint comme le successeur de françois
mitterrand à 9 heures c'est pour ça que
vous répondrez comme premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste
mais je pense que les français n'aiment
pas cette attitude qui c'est à dire les
jeux sont faits pour le reste les
contrats aidés les contrats aidés quand
il ya des besoins les a vus mais bon
mais là au premier trimestre ah non
monsieur on a juste fait en fonction des
critiques vous savez je sors pas de mon
chapeau tel un magicien
j'ai un tiroir secret dans lequel je
prends tout a été votée tout est clair
et vous imaginez vous imaginez si je
n'utilisais pas les outils voté par le
parlement
le reproche qui me serais fait ya les
contrats aidés je peux lancer un message
si certains départements notamment de
gauche accepté de jouer le jeu et ne
faisait pas de la politique politicienne
nous aurions pu sortir du chômage
davantage de personnes le département
des landes le département de l'aisne le
mien je les connais bien ils sont des
départements dans lesquels les conseils
généraux ne joue pas suffisamment le jeu
et n'offrent pas des contrats aidés
cofinancé par l'état
alors qu'on pourrait les offrir aux
titulaires du rsa
je vous dire une chose la gauche au lieu
de faire ces procès d'intention malvenue
ferez mieux de jouer le jeu de l'intérêt
général
très bien voilà pour cette réponse
frédéric dumoulin de l' agence
france-presse
donc nous rejoindre évidemment
l'aggravation du chômage durant le
quinquennat est un argument de poids
pour la gauche qui avance ses
propositions on en dire un mot alors
at-elle les solutions françois hollande
dans tous les cas promet de faire
baisser le chômage dont il vous est
revenue mois après mois de commenter les
mauvais chiffres neuf cent mille
chômeurs de plus dit vous en cinq ans
mais la gauche dit un million deux cent
mille
on voit ça avec tam tran huy être
ministre c'est pas tous les jours facile
pour xavier bertrand cela signifie une
fois par mois être le porteur de
mauvaises nouvelles depuis la crise
l'emploi est en berne
et depuis onze mois le chômage n'a cessé
de croître du coup le ministre du
travail trouve de bonnes nouvelles là où
il peut ce qu'on peut noter c'est que ce
premier trimestre de l'année 2012 et
celui qui donne les meilleurs résultats
depuis maintenant un an le chômage
continue d'augmenter mais moins que
d'habitude ce qui peut laisser espérer
un tassement
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord avec
cette analyse en france pour stabiliser
le chômage il faut créer cent cinquante
mille emplois et pour créer 150 emplois
il vous faut à peu près 1 7% de
croissance de l'activité en france
or y compris le gouvernement qui est des
prévisions assez optimiste prévoit 0 7%
de croissance pour cette année donc du
coup on sait que l'économie française
cette année va détruire des emplois
deuxième argument du gouvernement le
chômage en france augmentent moins
qu'ailleurs puisque 20% depuis le début
de la crise contre plus du double en
moyenne dans le reste de l'union
européenne
mais là aussi l'explication est biaisé
selon eric heyer
et il est vrai que le chômage a moins
augmenté en france qu'ailleurs mais pour
une raison assez évidente c'est que le
niveau de chômage avant la crise étaient
bien supérieurs en france et donc du
coup quand vous avez un faible taux de
chômage comme c'était le cas au royaume
uni ou aux états unis et qui ont
multiplié par deux ça fait une forte
augmentation même si le niveau reste
plus faible et donc ce qu'il faut
rajouter aux propos de xavier bertrand
c'est que le taux de chômage en france
restent à des niveaux extrêmement élevés
si on se compare aux autres pays
bref les chiffres on peut les accommoder
à sa façon c'est bien connu et xavier
bertrand est passé maître dans cette
gymnastique
il faut dire que le chômage constitue la
première préoccupation des français en
cette campagne électorale et qu'à droite
comme à gauche on semble le redécouvrir
depuis une quinzaine de jours
voilà donc on vient de le voir dans le
reportage
sarkozy a dit jah verserait la courbe du
chômage il avait donc déjà dit en 2007
est-ce que donc c'est toujours bien
l'objectif est est ce que cette fois-ci
il sera chiffré puisqu'il avait dit
pour cent de la population active je
m'en expliquer je m'en expliquer aussi
en tant que premier responsable de la
politique de l'emploi dans notre pays et
vous l'avez dit vous-même
j'ai toujours voulu assumer les chiffres
quand ils ont été bons quand ils ont été
moins bons en 2007 quand nous sommes
élus il y a un objectif de 5% pour la
fin du quinquennat
quand nous arrivons responsabilité le
taux de chômage est à 8 4%
un an après il avait tendance à 7,2 pour
cent c'est à dire le niveau le plus bas
depuis 1983 la crise arrive et là je le
dis l'objectif changé l'objectif premier
c'est de protéger au maximum les
français et d'éviter l'explosion du
chômage l'économiste le reconnaît le
chômage en france a moins augmenté que
dans les autres pays mentionnés lmnp
parce qu'il était déjà on nous a
expliqué m
pas seulement 20 % d'augmentation en
france en raison de la crise quarante
pour cent dans l'ensemble des pays bas
deux fois moins que c'est le fait du
hasard et donc la pole lors de la venue
possible et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi je vous expliquer pourquoi
donc je le dis parce que bien souvent
vous avez utilisé des chiffres tout à
l'heure le chiffre du parti socialiste
sont faux ça cherche à faire
spectaculaire c'est faux c'est un
mensonge
le chômage a augmenté d'un peu plus de
700 mille demandeurs d'emploi c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup trop
et d'ailleurs jeudi dernier quand il ya
la fameuse émission sur la deux françois
hollande et nicolas sarkozy ensuite
quand françois hollande on lui parle du
chômage ont mes tableaux perrière et le
chiffre qui apparaît c'est 700 milles de
plus pourquoi il n'a pas contesté
voilà pourquoi la réalité c'est qu'il ya
eu 700 mille demandeurs d'emploi de plus
c'est beaucoup trop
mais qu'il n'y a pas eu un million parce
qu'ils comptent donc cela ceux qui
travaillent à temps partiel
or quand on a un bulletin de paye à la
fin du mois jusqu'à preuve du contraire
on n'est pas chômeur quand vous dites
que les socialistes on compte hors de
d'avancé les chiffres qu'ils avancent
est-ce qu'ils ont tort également de dire
qu'il y a des plans sociaux en rafale
qui attendent pour apple si mais quand
arrive la liste d'ailleurs sont assez
d'accord là dessus quand on a eu le
jamie photowatt petroplus tous ces
dossiers là ils sont ils sont tellement
cacher ils ont été retardés ils ont été
voilà ils sont toujours là le maire de
l'avant mais essentielles y en a qui
sont sûrs ils sont sortis ce que vous en
créer d'autres vous même écoutez
automobile par exemple tout dépend de la
conjoncture économique
mais tant qu'on a une situation de la
croissance qui reste fragile
la situation de l'emploi restera fragile
mais il faut bien savoir une chose c'est
qu'ici il y avait un moment donné un
risque dans une entreprise
est ce que vous croyez pas que les
syndicats dans l'entreprise au comité
d'entreprise le dire est aussitôt et
vous vous ne prendriez pas l'information
aussitôt donc ce qui montre bien c'est
qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya des sujets
c'est pas le calendrier électoral qui
bloquerait les choses ou qu'ils
accéléraient les choses tout est sur la
place publique aussitôt et sur
l'automobile si je peux me permettre par
exemple qui enferme de malaunay vous
avez su vous installiez à voir ça au
coeur de la crise si nicolas sarkozy
françois fillon gouvernements ne
prennent pas les mesures
la prime à la casse tout le soutien à
l'industrie automobile
ça fait bien longtemps que vous auriez
eu de telles difficultés par nom de tels
drames
on les a évités je le dis parce que bon
on passe sous silence toute la politique
qui était la nôtre pendant la crise pour
éviter que le pays ne sombre mais
seulement tout ceci n'a pas été le fait
du hasard donc maintenant il faut aller
plus loin sur les cinq ans qui viennent
mais est ce que le ministre du travail
que vous êtes est davantage satisfait
par la tournure que semble prendre la
campagne de deuxième semaine du
président candidat plutôt que celle de
première que la première qui était
plutôt réorienter sur l'immigration le
un discours qui devait sous x qui devait
apparemment plus satisfaire l'électorat
du front national on parle toujours
autant de frontières est-ce que là est
ce qu'il ya une césure je vous le dis je
les avais je dit la même chose depuis le
début de la campagne
et si vous me permettez le modèle social
avoir un nouveau modèle social cela
repose par plus de travail
il faudra que l'on travaille davantage
et donner plus de travail à plus de
monde trouver des solutions sur l'emploi
des jeunes
c'est notamment le dispositif zéro
charges que nous mettons en place et
l'apprentissage y croit dur comme fer
c'est aussi très clairement l'emploi des
seniors le dispositif aussi zéro charge
pour l'entreprise qui recrute un
seigneur au chemin et c'est la formation
des demandeurs d'emploi celui qui
propose les mesures les plus solides les
plus puissantes pour faire reculer le
chômage
c'est nicolas saint pée deuxième fois
frédéric bulot là il ya la question de
l'immigration
oui c'est vrai que nous ne pouvons pas
dans les années qui viennent accueillir
autant d'immigrés que les années que
nous venons de connaître
il fut une époque où on faisait venir
des immigrés pour prendre des emplois
l'industrie automobile dans les années
70-80 aujourd'hui c'est plus possible de
la même façon et le troisième point pour
préserver notre modèle social c'est
aussi de lutter avec plus d'efficacité
plus de fermeté contre les abus les
gaspillages et les fraudes quel que soit
le sélectionneur dix jours le président
candidat était véritablement on en a
beaucoup parlé de l'immigration et la
missa même au coeur de son propos et
finalement aujourd'hui la présidente du
front national l'ua l'ue a rétorqué en
gros qu'elle ne choisirait pas entre lui
et françois hollande donc finalement
quelle surprise de sa part sont quel
scoop de la part de madame le pen donc
ces dîners où le docu nicolas sarkozy
donc depuis le départ pour l'afrique est
mise à mal depuis le départ au hall
savait où on s'en doutait que madame le
pen est perçue servicio attendait
franchement c'est ça en rien un scoop
la seule chose c est ce que les
électeurs de madame le pen se sentent
prisonniers de la consigne de l'absence
de consigne de bonheur de madame live
qu'ils étaient libres
dit oui mais de toute façon vous
inquiétez pas il ya dirigeants le dise
ou pas les gens s'en moquent ils peuvent
choisir un candidat
ils ne se sentent pas tenus ou encore la
position de leur gardien non je finis là
dessus c'est que eux par ailleurs est ce
qu'ils croient à la valeur travail est
ce qu'ils veulent faire la différence
entre le travail et l'assistanat est ce
qu ils veulent aussi
clarion clairement le droit de vote pour
les étrangers non communautaires aux
élections locales voilà les questions
qui sont posées et c'est pas les
consignes ou l'absence de consigne de
vote de tel ou tel dirigeant qui va
conduire à l'est du front national
justement est-ce que vous avez déjà
donné des interviews 1 minute vous non
non est ce que c'est et aurier on m'a
pas proposé pour la réponse est la même
vous diriez non vous conseiller que ça
n'est pas un journal qui se situe dans
le cadre républicain
je partage avec vous dis mais on ne lui
donnerait aux non parce que voilà non
parce que nous je vous dis monsieur
écoutez je ne vois pas pourquoi je je
m'adresserai à eux mais je vais vous
dire un truc feu on dans une campagne
présidentielle
les sujets qui m'intéressent sur les
sujets de la présidentielle et je vois
pourquoi vous allez me posez la question
dans quelle amérique parce que tellement
de la défense gérard longuet qui a donc
dit c'est la première fois depuis que
l'ump a été créé qui a dit que madame le
pen pouvait être un interlocuteur pour
votre parti je ne le pense pas le projet
eu l'occasion de dire à gérard longuet
tout à l'heure au trocadéro avant le
début de la réunion jeudi je viens de
voir la dépêche afp
reprenant ses propos explique moi et il
a dit je vais préciser les choses ce
qu'il a fait si je ne me trompe mais
aussi la poursuite si vous voulez aller
la précision c'est si on peut se réjouir
que marine le pen n'est pas les mauvais
calembours de son père la seule majorité
de gouvernement possible et l'alliance
du centre et de la droite républicaine
ça me va très bien sympa vous savez très
bien mais je veux dire c'est pas du tout
ça c'est on parle on n'a jamais parlé d'
allianz le président n'a jamais parlé
des ans le
les restes de l'âge de majorité n'ont
jamais parler d'alliance monsieur
longuet n'avait jamais parlé l'alliance
dans son interview à minute
il disait qu'il y avait une différence
notable entre marine le pen et jean
marie le pen pour c'est le cas j'ai
toujours dit ma position est constante
le prénom a peut être changé mais le
reste n'a pas changé voilà donc vous ne
souscrivez absolument pas je voulais dit
tout à l'heure et mais par contre si
vous voulez que je vous parle d'un choix
d'un choix clair c'est celui de dimanche
il est entre nicolas sarkozy et françois
niveau-là four la seule question qui
nous est posée aujourd'hui est ce que
vous trouvez pas que c'est embêtant
justement parce que on vous avez l'air
de parler de certains recentrage dans
cette deuxième semaine on va pas
inverser les rôles je suis pas
journaliste
quand j'étais jeune j'avais envie d'être
journée je ne suis pas journaliste
aujourd'hui c'est vous qui m'avez parlé
de ce recentrage je vous dis la campagne
est la même depuis le départ la
stratégie est la même ligne même dans
cet état les thèmes sont suisses au
deuxième je suis sur scène je suis sur
cette logique le travail
la valeur travail la création de
richesse pour mieux partager les
richesses
on me dit que mon origine mon ancrage et
gaulliste social sam s'agit alors je
pense que c'est que ça me va bien mais
ça n'empêche pas aussi une très grande
fermeté sur les thèmes qui sont les
thèmes régaliens mais pour le reste je
pense oui mais qu'il peut aussi savoir
tendre la main à ceux par exemple qui ne
peuvent plus travailler au raison de
leur âge ou de leur handicap c'est ce
qu'a d'ailleurs fait le président la
république tout à l'heure alors
justement que des messages comme celui
monsieur longuet viennent polluer
notamment par rapport à monsieur bayrou
jeu s'exprime dans deux jours attendez
je lui ai dit je vous ai répondu voilà
ne s'est pas embêtant vis-à-vis de
l'électorat centriste qui est quand même
assez rétif à tout ce genre de nerval
gamme je comprends ce doit faire quand
même quelques minutes qu'on est le sujet
je m'en doutais je suis pas surpris j'ai
moi même dit à gérard l'onglet young est
tout à l'heure qu'est ce que c'est que
ces déclarations donc voilà j'ai entendu
il y avait senti en bété ou pas pardon
vous l'avez senti chez moi qu'il voulait
préciser ses protégés à ryad il ya des
responsables de l'ump qui en donnait
rendez vous à la presse s'y met pour
analyser la stratégie qui étaient mises
en oeuvre par nicolas sarkozy on va dire
c'est des gens venus de l'humanisme
comme on dit je pense à jean pierre
raffarin
c'est donc une façon de jeu par mois
entendu qu'on m'attribue aussi celle ci
étant justement justement alors est-ce
que vous aussi
vous estimez qu'il y a des doutes qui
sont légitimes sur la stratégie
droitière mise en oeuvre par le par le
président la république non parce que je
ne sais pas ce qu'est cette stratégie
droitière allées du travail mental aussi
beaucoup d'immigrants mais je ne vous en
non mais attendez écoutons nous oui je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure aussi quelle
place donner une modification de
politique d'immigration par rapport à
notre politique sociale quand on venait
pour prendre des emplois nous mêmes nous
avons demandé à des personnes de venir
de l'étranger
ce fut une époque rappelez vous cette
phrase de michel rocard bien sûr la
france ne peut pas accueillir toute la
magie alors en même si elle doit prendre
sa part
il me semble que c'est le cas nous nous
savons aussi être juste mais aujourd'hui
compte tenu de ce que l équilibre de nos
côtes nous ne pourrons pas accueillir
davantage en moi vous avez dirigé lui
aimé jacquet ou les choses avaient
dirigé lui-même parce que vous n'avez
pas le sentiment aujourd'hui que le
parti l'ump n'a jamais été aussi proche
de détail en avant dans le front
national par rapport à notre période que
c'est que cette caricature une question
alors je vais vous dire une chose la
dérive droitière la sécurité ce que ça
correspond selon vous à ces dérives oui
ça correspond je pense à une attente la
démarrante parti depuis saint quentin ma
ville est une ville très populaires dans
les quartiers populaires vous savez ce
qu'on me demande en priorité
l'installation de la vidéo protection
que j'ai commencé à installer dans la
ville les milieux populaires
les gens qui me disent quand on a des
enfants ma femme qui rentre tard le soir
je me sens plus rassuré s'il ya des
caméras de vidéo protection est ce que
ce sont des gens qui ont voté à droite
non est ce que ce sont des certains de
mes concitoyens qui sont attachés à ces
questions de sécurité oui la question du
droit de vote des étrangers
vous seriez surpris de voir que le refus
du droit de vote des étrangers non
communautaires aux élections est
certainement une question qui transcende
les clivages politiques traditionnels
bertrand si jamais par malheur le
président à un public n'était pas réélu
mais par malheur pour vous mêmes droits
aux journalistes y ont apprécié moi
j'apprécie mais maintenant je vois
tellement d'hebdomadaires où les
journalistes votent ou je vois qu'il ya
un hebdomadaire marianne où il ya
quasiment personne et sarkozy que vous
assumiez un formidable que miss éléments
laissaient des troupes une autre
couronne
une prise de position et se mettaient
donc le présent un public était battu
est ce que vous pensez vous justement
sur cette question du front national et
de et de des digues a bien maintenir
vous pensez qu'il y aurait une unité de
tous les ténors là dessus je suis
persuadé qu'elle que soit quel que soit
le résultat
et j'ai même d'ailleurs vu les propos je
leur ai dit de certains responsables de
la droite populaire au sein de l'ump qui
ont dit nous ne sommes pas une
passerelle
nous sommes une digue et ses propos sont
très importants et j'ai eu l'occasion
justement de saluer ses propos présager
une ultime question peut-être sur ce
thème en cas de duel législatif entre le
front national et puis un candidat du
parti socialiste que faites-vous xavier
bertrand sarkozy ou hollande votre
sarkozy et je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que tous nos ressources des
légistes en mai dans une chose moi j'ai
bien fait de venir ici ce soir parce que
parce que ces questions là on les pose
jamais sur le terrain je vais me parle
d'emploi ouais on me parle de ces
curieux grille mais ça nous ça nous en
sommes à nous l'imposer
oui d'accord je vous dis je dans ces cas
là vous m'invitez le 6 mai au soir où le
7 mai le matin et je vous répondrai sans
problème mais je vais vous dire une
chose c'est parce que dans ces cas là on
en vient très clairement à d autres
sujets que ce qui intéresse les français
et il faut pas s'étonner après soit
qu'ils s'abstiennent soit parfois qu'ils
votent pour des partis éloigné de la
politique ma position a toujours été
constant de pas d'alliance fa cup à
damier hollande et sarkozy veut voir
tazir cosy pas manquer entre don que
fillon et copé pour la tête de l'ump où
voter qui pourquoi le sujet sur la table
aujourd'hui on est on sait jamais si ça
devait se poser bah je vous répondrai le
moment venu non je ne pense pas je ne
peux alors oui j'en ai une mais je ne
confonds pas je ne mélange pas les
échanges vous assure c'est pas que j'ai
peur de m'engager ce n'est pas dans mon
tempérament d'avoir peur mais la seule
chose c'est que je ne confonds pas les
échéances il ya le 6 mai et pour moi
aujourd'hui il n'y a que cela qui compte
merci frédéric elle je pense je crains
peut-être trouve plus à lui apprend que
ces questions reviennent dans les
minutes qui arrive avec perrine tarneaud
on va d'abord vous retrouvez donc je le
disais tout à l'heure en visite sur le
terrain fabrice cunay vous a observé
récemment c'était à saumur
l'heure est donc à la mobilisation vous
l'avez dit pas encore à l'affichage
d'ambitions personnelles même s'il peut
arriver que d'autres s'en chargent pour
vous reportage voyous pour ce gros quart
d'heure de retard
à saumur xavier bertrand est en retard
mais dans la course à la prensa la
sarkozie le ministre du travail serait
l'un des mieux placées même si pour
l'heure il préfère parler élections
plutôt que succession alors loin de
l'effervescence qui entoure son candidat
il bat la campagne
cet après-midi-là rendez vous pour
défendre un bilan et vendre un programme
face à une trentaine de chefs
d'entreprises locaux parlent beaucoup de
sondages en ce moment c'est mieux qu'un
sondage une réunion comme celle ci mais
n'hésitez pas être direct c'est bien
mieux
une heure de discussions directes durant
laquelle le ministre a tenté de faire
oublier une campagne pas toujours
convaincantes ici les photos sont
peut-être une déconnexion entre la
politique est l'art et économique donc
c'est intéressant de pour en discuter
il y un thème dont xavier bertrand ne
veut pas discuter la presse y met et au
delà la présidentielle 2017
mais ses amis politiques en parlent pour
lui j'espère qu'il va s'entraîner pour
pour 2017 parce qu'il fait partie de
tout ce qu'ils ont je crois la
possibilité d'aller beaucoup plus loin
et notre pays a besoin d'eux
de gens comme lui et qui sont des gens
pragmatiques les gens de terrain avec
beaucoup d'expérience voilà alors pour
l'instant occupons-nous déjà de deux du
6 mai 2012 et de gagner 6 mai 2012
jouer les vrp en attendant peut-être de
jouer sa propre carte
jean françois copé françois fillon
xavier bertrand à l'ump ils sont
plusieurs à tenir ce rôle
un pareil j'ai de l'ambition c'est vrai
mais mon ambition de première première
c'est le 6 mai le deuxième tour plein
qui pensent à la presse qu' on parle il
faut parler d'une seule chose le 6 mai
le 6 mai de s'immerger dans le cercle
des ambitieux à l'ump xavier bertrand
sait qu'il peut s'appuyer sur son cv
maire ministre secrétaire général
quel sera son avenir une chose est sûre
à raison d'un déplacement par jour il a
pris goût à la campagne présidentielle
perrine tarneaud nous a rejoint et
triplement prévenu des questions qu il
est difficile d rica d'aborder avec vous
ce jour donc nous sommes à cinq jours du
6 mai en parler puisque vos amis en
parlent pour vous mais j'ai une question
à vous poser pourquoi finalement que
j'avais bertrand autant de combativité
puisque sans doute au fond de vous-même
vous souhaitez un petit peu la victoire
françois hollande n'ont pas pourquoi ça
j'ai pas envie de payer des impôts moi
en plus j'avais pas vous gagner autant
d'argent
pourquoi nous dire pourquoi pas besoin
d'être super riches pour payer les
impôts ça c'est la grande fable de
monsieur hollande vous inquiétez pas je
ne demanderais d'efforts à personne les
super-riches perron
sauf que il n'y a pas assez de super
riches en france j'ai un couple
d'enseignants chez moi saint quentin qui
me dit l'autre jour monsieur le maire on
n'est pas de droite
on a fait nos comptes si c'était
monsieur hollande ça nous coûterait cher
et bien tout leur bon sens ils ont fait
les calculs le premier choix et c'est
celui-là
puis ensuite je voudrais vous dire une
chose je vais enfants j'ai pas envie que
mon pays prennent du retard et j'ai pas
envie que mon pays passe en seconde
division parce que quelqu'un qui soit ne
sait pas où il va soit n'est jamais
clair sur ce qu'il veut faire
c'est inquiétant à plus d'un titre et je
pense que c'est ce qui empêchera une
majorité de français de lui donner
un bulletin de vote je crois que la
différence il y a un doute sur françois
hollande
le doute le doute que les français eux
jugent moi je suis certain je suis
certain qu'il y ait de sa part qu'elle
donne une peur panique d'être
impopulaire à chaque fois qu'il a avancé
non mais les 60 ans il a laissé entendre
à certains qui reviendrait dessus et en
fin de compte uniquement pour les
carrières longues qu'il n'a jamais voté
c'est la droite elles sentent qu'ils ont
voté ces mesures pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler très jeunes
d'autre part sur le nucléaire regardez
un pas en avant deux pas en arrière sur
la question de l'euthanasie
je pense que c'est dans sa marque de
fabrique soit il ne sait pas où il va et
dans ces cas là c'est dangereux
soit il ne veut pas dire il n'est pas
sincère et là c'est gravissime dans les
deux cas de figure on ne peut pas lui
faire confiance et j'espère que demain
soir
ces choses-là apparaîtront très
clairement remis tour de la
présidentielle dans votre commune de
saint quentin il est arrivé en tête
françois hollande est dans votre commune
et dans votre circonscription
la vente circonscription il n'a pas été
deuxième ça va être difficile pour vous
la bataille des législatives comment
vous la santé en 2002 c'était déjà
pareil
en 2002 on l'oubli le score du front
national jean marie le pen et bruno
mégret était même à un niveau légèrement
supérieur
on connaît la suite on connaît la suite
il faut il faut aussi prendre un peu de
recul en politique et de regarder je
suis dans un département dans une région
qui a connu toutes les restructurations
économiques le textile depuis les années
70 et ce sont des régions taux de
chômage est plus important que la
moyenne ce sont des régions il faut
fournir plus d'efforts encore et j'ai
bien conscience que pour beaucoup de mes
concitoyens ils se disent est ce que
vraiment la politique sert à quelque
chose et je leur dis qu'en 2008 si on
n'avait pas eu un politique de la trempe
de sarkozy nous aurions connu des
situations bien pires mais c'est
difficile
quelques années après que de rappeler
aux gens qu'ils avaient peur à l'époque
pour leur économie et leur épargne et
l'autre par certains me disent mais
notre porte monnaie il compte pour nous
et pour nos enfants
avec la crise leur porte-monnaie n'a pas
augmenté autant qu'il aurait voulu et je
dois expliquer qu'en tout état de cause
si c'était les socialistes s'ils
l'emportaient la leur porte-monnaie en
prendre un sacré coup
en tout cas pour revenir aux
législatives il ya quand même un risque
important de triangulaire avec le front
national
avec la même chose en 2002 vous savez
avec la gauche mais alors qui est le
mieux à même à droite pour mener cette
bataille des législatives
est-ce qu'il doit y avoir un chef unique
jean françois copé par exemple tête de
la république l'a dit réélu il
s'impliquera davantage dans la campagne
des législatives
le père fait en 2007 et battu je me
place pas dans ce cas de figure
d'accord mais j'imagine que vous vous
êtes d'accord avec moi vous n'êtes pas
dans l'improvisation triste excusez moi
quand je me donne je me donne à fond
quand je me concentre je me concentre à
fond parce que j'y crois je pense que
cette victoire nous l'obtiendrons
certainement sur le fil par rapport aux
sondages
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de français
qui sont indécis et beaucoup de français
qui attendent demain soir demain soir
n'est pas un quitte ou double mais
demain soir vous retour pause mais
désormais l'eau sur le débat télévisé
face à l'augmentation non c'est pas que
tout repose dessus je pense qu'elle est
français qui ont un doute profond sur
sur françois alors il reste parce que
montrent les sondages je sais mais les
sondages ça peut bouger regarder les ce
débat de l'entre-deux tours n'a jamais
vraiment fait bouger des congrès oui et
puis jamais jamais un président sortant
ou une majorité sortante n'a réussi à se
maintenir autant qu'au premier tour de
la présidentielle en france ou en
espagne
les socialistes ont été balayés 15
points de retard par rapport à la droite
menée par tous en nous sortant non pas
du tout parce que dans tous ces pays la
semaine il n'y a pas eu un point et demi
d'écart il ya eu 15 points d'écart
nulle part et voilà pourquoi la
stratégie je le pense me et la bonne
c'est de parler au peuple à l'extrême
droite veut pas papa au centre seulement
nom à tous les français monsieur
hollande lui veut last ambitions
rassembler la gauche et l'extrême gauche
et nicolas sarkozy de rassembler les
français
ça fait toute la différence c'était le
message du trocadéro cet après midi mais
il ya des droites et pas une droite est
ce qu'avec un parti unique
vous n'avez pas à sécher complètement
votre lecteur mais j'entendais la même
chose en 2007 là c'était pas en 2002
mais en 2007 on a le droit aussi d'avoir
d'avoir de la mémoire onusienne et
regardez il est à 31% ram et c'est
dommage il a plus de réserves de voix
il était à 53% je pense que le score
peut être plus étroit que celui de 1974
comme valéry giscard d'estaing l'aveyron
porté sur françois mitterrand
il y avait quelques centaines de mille
voix je pense que ce score peut être
plus étroit et jeudi à celles et ceux
qui
qui veulent la victoire de nicolas
sarkozy qu'il faut convaincre convaincre
autour d'eux de façon à emporter
cette élection qui sera très
certainement serré mais les sondages
amont nous au début a sorti des
primaires monsieur hollande était à 35%
daviau il a aujourd'hui 62 % le premier
au deuxième tour les derniers sondages
donnaient à 53,53 et demi et je pense
que demain la confrontation le débat
peut changer la donne pour quoi regarder
la semaine dernière ce qui s'est passé
sur le plateau de la deux parce que
monsieur hollande a eu peur de faire
trois débats ce qu'est ce qui l'a
acceptée avec les socialistes aux
primaires socialistes non c'était pas
bon pour expliquer à tous les français
je ne l'étais pas vous avez l'un après
l'autre
aussitôt avec les mêmes interviewer et
derrière les français ont commencé à
voir la différence
demain ce sera face à face l'un en face
de l'autre
et là il sera compliqué pour monsieur
hollande de jouer l'expert de l' esquive
comme il est en permanence et c'est pas
pour faire plaisir à nicolas sarkozy une
réponse c'est tout simplement parce que
les français veulent savoir où ils vont
dans les cinq années qui viennent et
quelle est à la fois l'expérience et la
vision de chacun des candidats
alors vous parliez de france et de
citoyens il ya des citoyens qui peuvent
poser des questions à via leurs applis
orange tivi tchèque et un internaute
nous demandent pourquoi n'at-on pas dit
sous les 35 heures on en a fait
maintenant un plancher madame aubry en
avait fait un plafond et nous allons
faire un plancher vous savez quelle est
la durée moyenne du travail en france au
moment où chopard et nous dire 39.5
heures on est revenu au niveau d'avant
la loi mais symbolique dangereuse
pourquoi n'y a pas eu de rigueur
pourquoi ses impressions en belgique je
préfère être pragmatique que le
symbolique
si on avait remonté les 35 heures les
ouvriers perdait les heures
supplémentaires dès la 36e heure et je
leur dis d'ailleurs les heures
supplémentaires sont importantes
9 millions de français en font dans le
programme de monsieur hollande
il en parle peu c'en est terminé de la
vente ht pas pour les heures
supplémentaires dans les entreprises de
plus de 20 salariés pour commencer sur
ce thème soit vous avez dû batailler au
sein même de votre qu'en surgelé congé
assumé hier les assume ce soit je ne
veux pas privé pour briller des heures
supplémentaires monsieur hollande les
punir en revenant sur l'avantagé
supplémentaire et une autre question
avec l'application orange tv tchèque
question un peu plus nos dit comment les
militants ump ont ils pu tenir à 10 au
mètre carré au trocadéro ça c'est loïc
qui pose cette question
quel dommage qu'ils ne soient pas venus
quel dommage qu'il soit pas venu il
aurait voulu laisser sceptique et le jeu
les calculs derrière un bureau derrière
son ordinateur et d'être sur place ça
change quand même beaucoup on parlait
beaucoup il ya un monde fou
il nous faut beaucoup plus qu'on
imaginait faut parler beaucoup du duel
tgv est ce que vous estimez que nicolas
sarkozy veut aborder la question de dsk
moi je sais pas d'où que ça gênerait 1
c'est pas d'oxygène rêve c'est la mi
temps
mais c'est plutôt les sociétés temps
mais vous voyez là aussi qu'est ce que
ça cette saison dans le sens utile au
débat même si denses limpides que ce
sera utile aux dérapages ou ce poste
promo qui fixe la question du débat
demain mais à mon avis monsieur hollande
serait certainement plus embarrassé pour
expliquer pourquoi son directeur de la
communication pourquoi son directeur de
campagne
pourquoi pourquoi madame royal ils sont
les c'était pas si grave que ça lors ce
qu'a fait monsieur monsieur monsieur
strauss kahn
vous vous rendez compte un petit peu
mais si c'était des gens de cette gauche
caviar qui se réunit pour fêter déjà la
victoire ce que l'anniversaire da déjà
depuis un petit moment en rencontrant
monsieur strauss kahn alors même qu'un
moment donné j'étais là dire non non le
connaît quasiment pas franchement
heureusement que le ridicule ne tue plus
mais quand même ils ont besoin de
s'expliquer et imaginer imaginez si nous
avions et un moment ou un autre nous
n'avons pas eu la retenue que nous avons
eu dans cette affaire
vous imaginez si à un moment donné des
élus de notre sensibilité aura été dans
les circonstances le l'acharnement
qu'ont ory il ya deux poids deux mesures
un poids deux mesures et l'association
xavier bertrand un élu écologiste
grenoblois a réussi à obtenir via le
tribunal administratif de paris
les copies de 264 sondages commandés par
l'elysée pour un montant global de 6
millions trois cent cinquante mille
euros entre 2007 et 2009 1 seulement est
ce qu'on n'est pas là dans l'ivresse
sondagière c'est dommage que c'était lui
les pas demandé aussi pour les années
mitterrand
années chirac et commence à ce qu'il le
fait seulement maintenant lé coïncidence
en plus à moins d'une semaine après leur
bilan a quand même moi je les
coïncidences dans la vie pour lui croit
pas trop
c'est la chose qui est en retard sur le
fromage réponse il ya toujours eu des
sondages qui ont été faits y compris sur
le net à l'elysée mais tout est assez
c'est vrai que l'époque de monsieur
mitterrand ait pas de chantage sur le
groupe sur le 100 m a appris après coup
ne retrouve claire si les faits merci
xavier bertrand d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir merci bonsoir a très vite à tous
présidentielle décisif incontournable
suivez le face à face entre nicolas
sarkozy et françois hollande sur les
chaînes parlementaires
à l'issue du débat décryptage analyses
réactions avec les rédactions des deux
chaînes politique mercredi à 20h30
et
bonjour cette semaine nous sommes dans
l'ouest de la france au coeur du marais
poitevin
c'est la deuxième plus grande zone
humide de france après la camargue 20
mille hectares de verdure et de canaux
c'est l'équivalent de deux fois la ville
de paris mais aujourd'hui la venise
verte est menacée par la sécheresse et
l'exploitation agricole
alors comment protéger l'écosystème et
la biodiversité du marais poitevin
c'est ce que nous allons voir dans ce
nouveau numéro des pieds sur terre
à l'origine le marais poitevin était un
immense marécage ce sont les moines de
l'abbaye voisine de miles et qui au
xiiie siècle ont creusé ces canaux pour
pouvoir circuler dans le marais
victor tir est un jeune réalisateur de
documentaires nationale nature il
consacre son premier fils omar et son
enfance un marais aujourd'hui menacée
par le manque d'eau et l'exploitation
agricole
ce qu'on peut voir depuis quelques
années ce qu'on a un manque d'eau parce
qu'il ya moins de précipitation
simplement il ya moins de pluie à l'aîné
après on a surtout une gestion de cette
eau qui est on va dire un peu en
contradiction avec le milieu ce qu'il
est à l'origine
et ça se manifeste par notamment un
manque de crue l'hiver parce que sur
cette zone là les marais mouillé ici
normalement l'hiver au mois de juin dire
décembre janvier
vous imaginez que s'est recouvert d'eau
on peut naviguer en canot issue est en
fait depuis une trentaine d'années mais
on a moins de crues ou quand il y en a
on va dire qu'à dure moins longtemps
cette rue alors les conséquences qu'on
peut distinguer ça va être que le sol du
marais c'est de la tourbe et de pour 7
tourne pour qu'elle puisse vivre
elle a besoin d'eau et donc s'il n'y a
pas d'eau mais les terrains ont commencé
à s'affaisser et on va pouvoir le voir
sur les racines des peupliers qui vont
commencer à dépasser du sol donc saisir
ça peut être des peupliers ou les gens
qui ont construit leur maison a commencé
à s'affaisser petit à petit donc ça peut
être des conséquences économiques d'une
part après il peut y avoir aussi des
conséquences écologiques parce que le
marais poitevin baisse et une zone qui
inondait une partie de l'année et si
elle et non une partie de l'année
forcément il ya une faune et une flore
qui s'est installée et cette faune et
cette flore mais elle a besoin d'eau et
s'il ya plus d'eau à disparaît sans eau
toutes ces espèces végétales animales
qui sont se sont installés ici parce que
justement il y avait ce phénomène de
crue et ba sao toutes ces espèces vont
disparaître on va voir disparaître le
marais poitevin le milieu marais mouillé
qui est si on va dire exceptionnelle est
spécifique à cette zone de l'ouest de la
france
on préserver le marais il faut donc
maintenir les prairies par le pâturage
aujourd'hui seuls quelques éleveurs
perpétue cette tradition ancestrale
allez on va mettre plus de news
dominique moine et éleveurs ce matin il
amène ses va jusqu'à des parcelles
inaccessible du marais objectif
réhabiliter par le pâturage des prairies
jusque là abandonné
on
ce matin nous avons fait une mise à
l'herbe des animaux sur le marais
inaccessible par voie de terre donc nous
faisons ça pour entretenir le marais et
faire que les ce marais soit on va dire
plus agréable à voir et à visiter par le
pâturage grâce aux animaux le marais est
entretenu et effet un entretien
naturelle du marais dominique pourquoi
vous avez décidé de perpétuer de vous
prendre cette tradition qui était oublié
aujourd'hui nous sommes huit éleveurs à
faire ce travail sur sur ce marais
autrefois il est vrai tous les
maraîchins avait un ou deux ou trois
animaux et donc entre deux entretenaient
se marrait normalement nous avons
quelques z environnementales sur les
prairies et après nous faisons aussi pas